kilowatt activates Godspeed and travels
at a pace of 240 km/h as such how long
would it take kilowatt to travel from
cuckoo Mountain to Heaven's Arena on a
dark and stormy day whilst being pursued
by a Lemmy it's a simple question but no
matter how many times gone does the
maths you can't quite figure out that
the answer is subscribing to this
channel for regular Hunter hunter
updates straight to your YouTube feed
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we're going to talk
about one of the greatest lurking
threats within the entire on down two
world and one that for the most part
goes by completely unnoticed by fans
being Jireh now if you don't remember
gyro or you sort of running vaguely
remember the name well that's what
today's for because we are going to be
getting into why this man is without a
word of exaggeration
one of the most unparalleled threats
within Hunter hunter as well as what
role he may play in the future but first
up I think it's very important to recap
this very fleetingly Future character as
well as highlight the difference between
his appearances in both the anime and
the manga because I'll tell you right
now if you have only watched the 2011
anime series there is a very key
difference that may make gyro something
of an underwhelming random character
from your perspective and I really don't
understand why it was changed in the
anime adaptation it's just one of those
weird things I mean especially since
they went to all the trouble to adapt
the character at all but whatever but
that very very important difference is
that gyro was actually present in dolly
city when Gon and Killua
were training to face off against
knuckle and shoot in order to earn the
right to join the Chimera ant
extermination team and not only that but
we were made aware that gyro was on the
very same street where GaN killer and
knuckle were currently present in that
narration went as follows gone and gyro
did not end up meeting and gyro left
this town and disappeared somewhere
whether that was fortunate for the two
of them or not it will remain unknown
until they eventually meet so incredibly
ominous words there that goes so far as
to set up gyro as a major character if
not a major antagonist for the future of
hunter hunter now whether or not you
subscribe to that train of thought is of
course entirely up to you and your own
personal interpretation but I have come
to take these words quite seriously and
I think that feeling only solidifies
when we look back on drivers passed and
his context within the story because
it's actually pretty insane how much we
know about this character when in the
grand scheme of things he has had almost
zero narrative impact to us far there
are far more theoretically important
characters in the series whose past
not been touched on whatsoever but for
some reason we know gyro quite
intimately so much so that almost an
entire chapter is dedicated purely to
exploring him and just to briefly go
through what we know basically driver
grew up in a construction camp the son
of a very poorly paid worker who spent
his days and nights engaged in a drunken
stupor he would also allegedly almost
never speak to gyro which impeded his
development but not only that his father
would of course beat him furiously if
gyro bothered him in any way shape or
form which included making creaking
noises from rolling over in his sleep as
such not only did gyro learn to lay
bricks before learning how to speak but
he also forced himself to sleep without
moving a single muscle living by his
father's mantra which was don't make
trouble for anyone and those were
effectively the only words he ever
stated to his son but even with all of
this gyros still believe that his father
loved him despite all of the evidence
clearly stating otherwise but the moment
when this would all change is when gyro
got into an altercation that his father
stumbled upon but instead of doing the
fatherly thing and helping his son Jerez
father just walked away leaving him to
be savagely beaten and at this point
gyro formed a core truth within himself
which was that the world may the
universe did not care about him and
coming to the conclusion that he was not
human this would be the only true lesson
he learned from his father
setting up the rest of gyros existence
and shortly after this event gyro
murdered his father by cracking his
skull open with a hammer stole what
little money he had and left the
construction camp with a profound hatred
of all humanity as well as the
determination to see it suffer and it
has actually been said that gyros
driving will is to spread evil
throughout the entire world
now apologies for the history dumped
there but I do think the jurors past as
well as the extreme detail we know it in
is very important to this discussion
because this is some serious backstory
for a character who as far as we know
may never appear in the series again
that's not quite the end though either
because nine years after leaving the
camp gyro went on to form ng L the near
green autonomous life zone which
eventually became its own nation and is
best known to us as the location where
the chimera ants began their reign of
terror upon this world and actually
during said reign of terror Jireh was
killed and consumed by the Chimera ant
queen although his fate from there was
radically different to most chimera ant
victims because the thing about gyro
that I haven't mentioned as of yet is
that the series goes to great lengths to
describe him as a proud king which is
stated by the narrator in the
to most likely be the reason why he was
so easily able to resist the Queen's
control and move freely in his new
chimera ant body so there was no moment
whatsoever where gyro was under the
control of the chimera ants
he just reincarnated and went off his
own way that and his determination to
spread pure evil throughout the world is
what kept his human memories intact and
this is incredible because no other
chimera ant has followed this trait
forward a path I mean yes other ants
have eventually regained some of their
memories and become something of the
people they used to be prior to being
killed but gyros memories Drive and
pride were so unwaveringly powerful that
he was never at any stage anything less
than what he was prior to his
consumption and that should truly
terrify you the fact that this man's
desire to plunge humanity into despair
by spreading pure evil throughout the
world is so strong that a transcends the
process of death is nothing short of
astounding it would be a very difficult
task to find a character in Hunter
hunter who sheer will is anywhere near
the level of gyros Tropico is probably
the closest I can think of but to be
honest jairos desires kind of make crop
occurs revenge quest look pretty cute in
comparison and what's worse is that gyro
was reborn into the vessel of a chimera
ant thus giving him access to
potentially devastating power especially
if he learns to harness his aura through
nen in fact I'll say it right here and
now if gyro is able to become aware of
ant master nen it's just game over for
the world nan is a wonderfully unique
power system because it basically is an
expression of pure will and desire that
allows it to use it to harness their own
life force to produce an outcome that
they feel strongly about and gyro as
we've established feels pretty damn
strongly about evil and I want to
emphasize that because in storytelling I
think the word evil is thrown around far
far too haphazardly it's often used to
describe characters who I think would be
far better label to something more basic
like narcissistic selfish or even an
extreme dick that or gets applied to a
boring monotonous demon style character
who can't be anything but bad for the
sake of bad but evil here in regards to
gyro is being used with its intended
meaning we're talking profoundly
corrupted humanity with sinister
intentions that I don't even think a
demon could ever hope to match and when
we're talking about evil I once again
struggle to find any character in the
series who could even compare to Jireh
like I would never call Hisoka or
Crowell Oh evil characters per se they
are antagonistic and morally ambiguous
but evil no absolutely not
they take far too much
enjoyment from being human and in the
case of Cola they do actually have their
own code of morality you could maybe
make the argument that 4th prince
erratic of the [ __ ] in Empire represents
evil and he is certainly one of the more
terrifying characters I think we've ever
encountered but once again this man is
driven by a sense of enjoyment for what
he does which in his mind is creating
art jyro on the other hand takes no
enjoyment from his actions they aren't
performed to satisfy him personally they
are performed for the sake of evil pure
and simple it is a raw undiluted force
and it is going to go completely
unchecked within the hunt underworld and
that's not to say that there aren't
characters aware of gyro that definitely
are such as well Finn and in cargo who
eventually recalled their previous lives
as his subordinate and in fact wealth
and believes that gyro would be headed
to meet your city in order to rebuild
his nation and set his ultimate plan
into motion
not that well Finn is going to try and
stop him though in fact he seems more
eager to join Jerez cause believing
greatly in his former leader which is
also absurdly dangerous because it shows
that gyro possesses the charisma to warp
the minds of those around him to form
the building blocks of disseminating
evil and this wolf and train of thought
is also quite important because he is
well aware of nen and if gyro isn't and
he certainly will know of its power if
and when wellthen finds him in meteor
city so at this point I believe it's
incredibly clear that Takashi did at
least at one stage set gyro up to be a
major presence not just because of
focusing on his past or by that ominous
narration of how he and Gaughan are
ultimately going to meet but through
characters like well fanatic algo who
have these connections to him that go on
to drive their own characters it would
all just seem like a bit of a waste of
this man just disappeared into the ether
but we do have to face a narrative
reality of hunter hunter as well because
currently the greater cost of the series
have left the human realm and on route
to the Dark Continent
so for Jerry to be playing a part in
this he would need to be on his way as
well but I see limited possibilities in
regards to why he would do such a thing
and this is because gyros primary
mission has to do with humanity so he
has no real reason to leave the center
of Lake Mobius if anything that's
counterproductive because it's taking
him away from humans the only logical
reason I could see for gyro traveling to
the Dark Continent
would be to perhaps purposely bring back
another calamity and set it loose upon
humanity but even then I find it far
more likely that if gyro were to return
to the story it would be after the
events of the Dark Continent which I
know seems like an awfully impossibly
long time away but perhaps something
could happen along the line
of our characters returned to the human
realm and discovered that gyro has
ravaged the entire human world
thoroughly with evil and have to stop
him all perhaps gyro story plays out
simultaneously with the Dark Continent
arc so while everyone else is away it
falls to go on and maybe kill one to
face off against gyro in the human realm
whatever the case toga she almost
certainly had a very clear idea of how
gyro was going to be used in the future
but this being Hunter hunter I have to
admit that he could easily change his
mind at a whim he may have gotten bored
of the idea well he might just think
that there's no chance of getting to the
point where it comes to fruition and
actually it's not like this whole gyro
thing was always guaranteed to go
somewhere because hunter hunter did have
a natural ending with grown and Jing
even toe Kashi stated that he has
effectively ended the series once and
often thinks that maybe he should have
just left it there but the story keeps
going and as a result we will keep
questioning its future and gyro was one
of those questions that rather
unfortunately may never be answered
which is a shame because from everything
we know about him he has the potential
to be one of the most interesting
antagonists in the entire series he
would be an exploration of what it
really means to actually be evil and
it's a sort of idea that I know Takashi
would be able to rock and a great way to
cap off the series but whether or not
this ever comes to fruition always
remember that this man well well I guess
not a man anymore because even when he
was human he didn't consider himself a
man so always remember that this force
of pure evil is lurking within this
world and whether it happens in front of
our eyes or not he is going to unleash
quite literal hell on earth at that
pretty much does it for this discussion
on Shiro if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of you amazing people
is what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on Shiro and his potential
future in hunter hunter this has been
the New World review and I'll see you
next time
you
[Music]